[Music]
The House of the Dragon season 2 is
coming in a few months and with it the
giant monsters in the form of the
targaryan Dragons the biggest of them is
the old green Dragoness of aegon the
Conqueror who is by now 184 years of age
as of the show the second biggest is the
bronze Fury who is almost 100 years of
age and almost as big but how big really
is he here in this video we will assess
the size of veror by assessing its
appearance in the last episode of the
show and also by looking at the concept
art as well as taking the book
definitions into consideration and when
we are done with all that we will pitch
them one against another and see if the
bronze Fury is in fact more powerful and
more fearsome than the old vagar so
let's get to it guys how big is vagar
according to information given by the
VFX artist working on the house of the
Dragon series vegar was reported to have
a length of 150 M equivalent to nearly
500 ft from its s to the end of the tail
the dragon possesses a serpentine-like
body typical of others of its kind
covered in reptilian scales with a
predominantly green coloration and
accents of yellow and bronze so with a
body size of 500 ft the estimated
wingspan would range between 900 to
1,000 ft across meaning 270 to 300 M
wide however observations from the
episode where aan bonded with Vegas
indicates a dragon head with a young
tararan nearby appearing to be around 20
to 25 ft long just ahead and
extrapolating this we would suggest or
estimate a body length of approximately
80 M or over 260 ft and consequently the
wings span would be in the ballpark of
150 M or 500 ft but that's just our
estimate now how big is vermar in the
bgs so firstly vermar a bronze dragon
was already a sizable creature at the
age of 14 in the year 48 AC ranking as
one of the largest dragons alongside
Bion and vagar as the events of the
draft of the Dragons unfolded 80 years
later veror approaching a century in age
had become the second largest dragon and
no other dragons come close to its size
you know other than the bigger vagar
despite being a fearsome Beast he had
grown accustomed to human interactions
and by the reign of agon II vermar was
in Dragonstone along with the other wild
dragons and also with Silverwing he was
brooding there just chilling and
awaiting another the person of targarian
bloodline to born with in the book
vermal size is described as supposing
the combined size of sea smoke and
Tarion both of whom were noted to be
only oneir the size of vagar the reason
for Vera's exceptional growth was
attributed to its residence and dragon
Stone along with wild dragons not to
mention his genetics so this allowed him
more freedom ample food and the ability
to choose his own layer unlike the
dragons affected by the dragon pit
unfortunately which unintentionally
caused the dragons to shrink in size
veror did not suffer from this or such
constraints considering sea smoke was
1/3 the size of vagar and also stated to
be less than half the size of vermar
this implies that vermar size ranged
from 70% that of vear at the very least
up to 80% of Vega's size at the most now
how big is veror in the show so in the
last episode of season 1 we got the
chance to see the bronze Fury in a cave
being coded by Damon Targaryen at first
it looked to be almost as large as vagar
but upon close inspection it seems to be
that the bronze Fury was around the same
size as what stated in the books
therefore around 70 to 80% of the size
of vegar now if vegar was 150 M or 500
ft long as officially stated that means
veror would be 105 to 120 M long or 344
to 400 ft long its wingspan would
therefore be 750 to 800 ft wide or 230
to 244 M across now going to our more
more reasonable estimates if Vega was 80
M or 260 ft long that would mean that
the veror dragon was around 56 to 64 M
or 183 to 210 ft long and with a
wingspan of around 400 ft wide or 122 M
this means that to the Casual man on
King's Landing streets vermar would
appear to be as big as vagar and only if
they were seen together side by side
with the difference with the size
difference really show now how powerful
is veror contrary du to his namesake and
popular belief the bronze Fury wasn't
actually really that Furious he was
actually torent of humans unlike the
wild dragons which is why he boned so
closely with King jaras the wise the old
and peaceful King VOR before the dance
of the Dragons was never recorded to
have been in any battle against any
other dragon with his Flames only being
let loose against wildings and other
human armies and ships therefore his
battle experience is pretty low although
his size makes up for his lack of combat
prowers his own only dragon on Dragon
Battle would be in the Second Battle of
tumbleton where he was attacked all of a
sudden by sea smoke from above as he was
about to take flight nevertheless he
still dominated the fight and even with
Taran jumping into The Fray he was able
to tear off the head of the ashy gray
dragon and in the chaos of the fighting
caused mortal wounds to Tarion as well
but this battle would also CA him his
own life as well in the
process now can veror take on vagar in a
fight well this depends on different
factors you see Size Doesn't Really
always mean a win in the case of the
targaryan Dragons Vega was killed in
fighting Caris a dragon half her size
VOR was also killed fighting sea smoke
and Tarion which are pretty small
compared to him vear is bigger than
vermar of course but not really by a lot
she also has more battle experience than
him which is a great Advantage
especially in fights against other
dragons but veror is younger meaning
more stamina and fury he is also a a
male dragon which makes him more rageful
when provoked and then since he is a bit
smaller he would be faster and more
Nimble and this tiny difference in
agility would make up for the slight Gap
in size so the bronze Fury might come
out as a winner 30% of the time and 30%
of the time he would lose and the rest
40% of the time they would just kill
each other now I hope I've answered the
question is vagar or veror stronger well
it depends on the situations they might
just kill each other now if you like
this video then watch this other one as
well and do check out our channel for
other monster content now like subscribe
and we'll see you in the next video take
care
fam